يوما كان الأرنب
بسرعته مسرور
للسلحفاة ذهب
متبخترا مغرور
يا سلحفاة يا بطيئة
هيا تعالي نتسابق
حسنا حاضر يا مغرور*** لا مانع إني أوافق
يا سلحفاة يا بطيئة *** هيا تعالي نتسابق
راحا في طريق الغابة  ***   بخفته الأرنب يجري
بدأ بسرعته القصوى   ***   والسلحفاة خلفه تمشي
خلفي تركت السلحفاة   ***   هيهات ستلحق هيهات
والآن سأرتاح قليلا  ***    وأنام لبعض اللحظات
أرنب أرنب يا مغرور **** أرنب أرنب يا مغرور
السلحفاة تخطو للفوز**** بثبات منها وإصرار
ولخط وصولها لحقت ****  وحظيت بالتشجيع الحار
نهض الأرنب من نومه *** وانطلق ليكمل عدوه
وصل هنالك وتفاجأ ***   بالسلحفاة وصلت قبله
ويلي ويلي كيف خسرت  ***  ماذا جرى أين المنطق
كيف لها أن تربحني  ***  أنا أسرع لست أصدق
أرنب أرنب يا مغرور **** هذا درس المتكبر
لا تغتر لكي تنجح ****  ومن غيرك لا لا تسخر
ومن غيرك لا لا تسخر